hi my name is Donna she didn't I'm
currently playing the role of a product
owner for an enterprise solution at
Bosch taking up the simple loans data
sent his master's program helped me in
understanding how the data has to be
handled and also in pursuing and
expectations of the clients so this is
my story as a product owner I wanted to
come out with a solution where I had to
deal with a live data for the project
managers for the project excellence
delivery and also coming up with
matrixes which would support them for
the project execution to do this I have
to obscure myself in the area of data
science where I have to look for some
kind of a certification so while
exploring they had a lot of Institute's
which came up in mind but Dean aerodrome
would simply learn the training but that
simply known was really great as I also
invite rated before like the flexibility
and learning was the great thing and
then the trainer's so it was an live
training so it was something like where
the trainers could put the topics and
you could ask questions via the chat box
so it was nothing like where the trainer
was only going on talking and you had to
just observe but it was an interactive
session but it developed me to become an
an effective product owner and also it
created a visionary idea like what my
clients would require in future being in
the role of a product owner it becomes
crucial that I know the technology that
my team is creating with the help of the
data scientist master's program I was
able to achieve that thank you simply
learn